Hello BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
Moco-chan.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 136th episode!
BAU BAU!
I was thinking maybe you won't get it right.
136th... BAU BAU!
I was joking to Moco-chan how it's our 5,000th episode today.
BAU BAU!
But it is Wednesday.
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today!
It's too early!
Too early for 5000, not for Wednesday.
I get it now.
The week does go fast, but I will be seeing some new Ruffians here today!
And wow, for those who are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO morning!
BAU BAU!
I see you know some Ruffians say, oh there's always new Ruffians huh?
This is Ruffians!
We see you!
Ruffians!
We see the silly things you say!
The hour before FUWAMOCO Morning starts!
I'll be back, Ruffians!
I'm gonna go watch this!
I'm gonna go do that!
Alright!
We see lots of movies, you know!
Today's my first time watching FUWAMOCO live, you know!
So it makes us happy to see you, Ruffians!
And of course, Ruffians are always where we recognize you, you know!
Of course!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
But you know, it's the middle of the week already!
That means the week's almost over, really, if you just kind of look at it a different way, right?
October's over.
But it hasn't gotten to the most exciting part of the month.
Pumpkin.
Leaves changing colors.
Apple cider.
Maybe it has already though.
Maybe we just don't know how.
Maybe.
But it's still not quite the spookiest time.
That's good.
BAU BAU!
You've been having lots of fun during October so far, Ruffians!
And now!
More fun!
It's time for disappointment.
Why is it always disappointment, Moco-chan?
Cause...
Natural.
Pero Sighting.
Okay.
Where was Pero Sighted and now Ruffian?
I feel like the Ruffians don't look that disappointed anymore.
It's okay if they're not disappointed for a Pero Sighting.
Well, let's show them what disappointment really looks like then.
Let's show them!
Where is Pero Sighting now, Moco-chan?
De-den!
Oh!
Hi!
Did we get confused?
Did we skip my turn?
Today I went on a walk!
Uh... Hi!
No!
This is a Pero Sighting.
It's disappointing, you know.
Don't you see that?
Ah!
See Pero!
Pero is hiding there!
Right in the ice cream!
Right by the Mococo- In the Mococo drink!
Right!
Why is Pero doing in the Mococo drink?
Come on!
Right, that's what I was wondering, you know.
It's not a very good place.
Right, Ruffians?
Hiding in the ice cream.
I mean, I guess it is a drink, but Ruffians, if you have ice cream in your drink, do you eat the ice cream first or drink the drink first?
Ice cream first.
Because if you drink all the drink, then you're just left with ice cream on ice.
Yeah.
Why?
Ice cream first, ice cream first, ice cream first.
Common sense is ice cream first.
Mix it up!
Do you have ice cream left on the ice?
Well, I don't know though.
I was wondering, how did Pero get in there?
I don't think that's on the ingredients list, right?
It's a bit weird, huh?
You know, maybe I need to go to Round1 and investigate what's going on there, Ruffians.
Yeah, I know.
You'll just have to go and see how much fun is happening there.
Check that maybe Pero isn't around.
Right!
Not just because we want you to go to Round1, right?
No, definitely.
We're definitely not envious.
Yeah.
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
Look!
Look, there's some of me!
You know, they got a forgettable Pero, but they got a FUWAMOCO coaster!
Yeah, right!
And a drink, too!
And a little bit extra.
Something nasty extra.
Not a hair, but worse.
I'm not envious about that.
The other stuff...
Maybe.
Yeah.
You're a bit envious of Pero.
Don't need to be envious of Pero.
You're better than him.
Better than Pero.
Morning!
BAU BAU!
MAMA!
Perotis, I don't wanna find that out.
You're gonna have to find that out.
The next stop of the FUWAMOCO unofficial world tour has been announced!
We have just announced as guests at Anime Frontier in Texas!
America!
The middle.
America yo!
BAU BAU!
We're so happy and so excited!
We're gonna be able to see some more videos soon!
Even though I say soon, well, soon's kinda soon.
We'll be at Anime Frontier on December 7th!
Saturday!
And I really hope that there'll be lots and lots of Ruffians there to see us and, you know, BAU BAU up a storm with us too!
A little bit over a month, right?
Just look at October, it's soon, okay?
It's soon, it's really soon.
But you know, we always get a little nervous before big events like this.
We really hope that you'll come cheer us on and you'll show just how big a Ruffian you are!
I'm a Ruffian!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
What do they say?
That's the Japanese dub, right?
I'm a big ol' Ruffian here.
That's it.
That's the Texas accent, okay.
BAU BAU!
We have to find Ruffians!
You have to teach us their anime frontier, okay?
Please bring your friends too, Ruffians!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
I'm so excited!
Another part of the FUWAMOCO unofficial!
Ask Karin-senpai for help with the text and action!
You mean...
Tanaka Cowboy Master.
Master Tanaka Cowboy Senpai!
Ruffians!
There's a battle going on.
A big one.
The battle that determines who is going to be the true, real, the actual FUWAMOCO.
The beautiful FUWAMOCO!
And will also determine who's the nasty, dirty FUWAMOCO!
Yeah!
That's because we're gonna be having a collab together with Koyori-senpai and Mami-senpai, who are the unofficially and lovingly referred to as dirty FUWAMOCO!
The loving part is important, you know?
Yeah!
I see the comments being like, wow!
Koyori!
Koyori-senpai!
Mami-senpai!
They're wonderful!
They're not dirty!
They're not dirty.
I know.
But, uh...
People saying that, oh no, this is what they're gonna be officially referred to as now from now on.
Oh no, it's more like a dirty pear reference, no!
But I would like to say, at first, Lamy-senpai, Koyori-senpai, they were known as the noisy FUWAMOCO, unicized FUWAMOCO.
I've suddenly switched to becoming dirty FUWAMOCO!
Is that because of Senchou-senpai?
Might be.
I don't- I don't see them as dirty!
Why dirty?
Maybe noisy?
Noisy.
Sure.
Yeah, but you know we'll be finding out who is the real FUWAMOCO when we battle each other in Mario Party Jump!
Yes!
Over on Koyori-senpai's channel early tomorrow morning at 5AM PT!
Impostor FUWAMOCO!
We are the impostors!
We are FUWAMOCO!
We have to find out tomorrow at 5am PT.
Not you, Aizako.
No.
Although, historically we're not the best tomorrow in Friday Night with Moco-chan.
There's not that much history.
There is twice.
Twice?
Twice.
Third time's the charm.
Third time is a charm, ha!
Please, please, please, please wish for a big day!
Otherwise, you know... I don't know what's gonna happen, you know?
Maybe I'll wake up and suddenly this'll still be the FUWAMOCO channel!
Maybe it won't look a little different, maybe.
You know?
I know.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Why Lamy-senpai?
Well, you know Lamy-senpai's kind of blue.
And Moco-chan's kind of pink.
I am pink!
I am not kind of pink!
Koyori-senpai's pretty pink too.
I am pink!
Mococo is pink!
Got it.
Moco-chan is very observant.
I'm pink.
Understood.
I am pink!
Yes.
If you keep on slamming the desk, your paws definitely aren't gonna be pink.
They already are.
Because I am pink!
Okay!
Go at it!
Yes.
Okay Moco-chan, okay.
Speaking of battles and Koyori-senpai!
Ruffians!
There's also another big battle going on right now!
At this very moment.
And that battle is hololive Koshien!
A big baseball tournament is organized by Koyori-senpai.
And actually involves all of hololive.
Do you know what koushien is?
Koushien.
It's a big national baseball tournament in Japan.
It can be confusing though.
I always read koushien as yochien.
It's kindergarten.
It's different.
No.
It's not kindergarten.
Not a kindergarten tournament.
But in this big tournament in hololive Koshien, the game is actually a Power Pro Baseball!
It's a game and there are five teams I think!
At least a couple of them are led by AZKi-senpai, Kanata-senpai, Koyori-senpai, and Ririka!
And they'll raise each team of theirs and bring them to the Koshien Tournament to find out which is the ultimate team, the team that will win the tournament!
And you know all the team members!
I'm hololive member!
And you know, of course with this kind of thing, there's drama and dreams coming true, or being crushed, that's all part of the experience.
But you know, right from the very first draft here, the draft meeting, the very beginning, there's already been a heartbreak.
Can you guess what it was, Ruffians?
Ruffians.
FUWAMOCO!
We've been separated from each other.
Moco-chan.
Moco-chan is going to school Kanate in Osaka!
And me, Fuwawa!
I'm going to koukou in Kyougoken.
Wakareyade.
Iwate!
We're gonna be spending the next three years separated.
Separated.
We're different demon dogs.
But you know what, Ruffians?
We'll reunite together one day on the baseball field.
And then surely legends will be made down in there, right?
Right.
That's how it works, right?
But you never really know how hololive Koshien is going to go.
So you don't even know about all of us hololive members are in it.
But we just actually kept playing.
We hope that you'll keep an eye on us and cheer for your favorite team!
I think you know what friends you should cheer for.
You should cheer for team Koyori!
Koyori-senpai will lead us to victory!
We'll smash the competition.
BAU BAU!
I don't know any baseball chants.
BAU!
KOIYO!
Moco-chan, you can't copy!
You can't copy Moco-chan!
Koushien?
Is that how it works?
I don't know.
BAU BAU!
I don't know anybody to choose from.
Well, I don't know.
Everybody likes to go to Koshien, right?
I don't know.
Oh, Ruffians!
Yes!
You know, FUWAMOCO, we've been very fortunate we survived.
You know, and, well, I was kind of thinking...
It's a box filled with exciting hololive lists!
FUWAMOCO!
How can the Ruffians get their own hololive merch subscription box?
I thought it would be pretty cool, right Ruffians?
We figured out an answer!
We did!
All fixed!
Yes!
You two can have your own!
Misty, hololive merchandise subscription box.
Misty, because you don't know when it's going to arrive.
Well, you just need to order some merch and you know it probably has a long pre-order window.
And then, you completely forget about it.
And then, suddenly!
Surprise!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
Hasn't been friends with you yet, huh?
But Ruffians, you know it could still be friends with you if you order them now!
They're on sale and I heard that they may be released sometime in November it seems.
Really?
I think that's what the shop said.
I don't know.
Wow, look what our next subscription box is gonna be like!
I don't know what I'm gonna get here, all of Advent!
Eventually though!
It'll surprise us!
Yes!
And then we'll be surprised.
BAU BAU!
The fuzzies are so cute!
Not Mocotami.
We think so too.
That's what we ordered all of.
FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians.
I have...
Is that why we're fighting for so long?
What's with the day to pick what the word is?
Sorry, Ruffians.
Just wait for FUWAMOCO to find the word, okay?
Do you want any help?
I think it starts with an A. A. Not an apology.
No.
Huh?
Not an announcement.
No, not an announcement.
Just adding a word.
I'm gonna start with an A. A confession!
No, I'm gonna start with a C. I don't know if it's a confession.
A confession!
In the comments.
Well, maybe this kind of leads into what I'm gonna say next.
A confession!
Today has not been a very fluffy day for me today.
Yeah.
Ahhhh.
Not an
No, it has noise!
It's just been one of those days where... It's kind of really... awkward.
A bit out of it.
Yeah.
You know, there's been multiple incidents.
One!
I was trying to get off the elevator.
Yeah, we were together with Morning-chan!
And I almost pushed somebody over.
Yeah.
And it felt really bad.
Morning-chan was late.
Morning-chan was late!
So I'm like, huh?
What?
And you're like...
Other person, are you good too?
Yeah.
And then.
Somehow.
I kind of... Almost... Surprised somebody so much they fell over too!
Yeah!
Yeah... Uh... Yeah... It was very close.
That was the second incident too, Ruffians!
Yeah... Fuwawa howl!
I don't know how!
Villain oink!
I was just standing there and then they almost died!
Yeah... Yeah...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Ruffians, you know, you're about to start your day off on the right paw.
I beat you.
Because I was way more embarrassed.
You have a lot of those!
Well, I beat you, so... Don't worry.
It's a fight now, okay?
Yeah.
You were beaten.
BAU BAU!
Hopefully tomorrow will be a bit more of a fluffy day.
Yeah, just a bit more fluffy.
Yeah.
Let's hope.
And you know, hopefully I can fall asleep properly and not think of... I just don't know how I should go.
But if I do well, that's just how things are sometimes.
BAU BAU!
What about a wrestling match?
A wrestling match against myself!
I think everybody does that outfit everyday, huh?
You shouldn't though.
That's an accurate description.
Because you do not deserve it!
BAU BAU!
I don't deserve that.
Moco-chan!
Did I start the Pup Talk already?
I think you started the Pup Talk already.
Hi!
Are you getting a Pup Talk today, Moco-chan?
You're so excited, it's just... It's going all out of bounds.
FUWAMOCO-chan, can we hear some more motivational words from you then?
I guess.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that time!
That time again!
The time of week!
Because this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it from me!
Straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians!
How are you feeling?
A bit cold.
A bit...
Hot!
A bit hot and cold!
Wow!
It's that time of year again, huh?
Where the seasons are changing, and it's hard to keep up, and it's easy to come down with a little bit of something to light.
Have you been sneezing a bit more than usual?
I know it can be a bit rough trying to take care of your everyday life and trying to stay up and date with the hustle and bustle of everything.
Maybe... Maybe your head feels like it's been installed backwards to how it usually is.
Ha.
Maybe some people are especially high.
Let's do our best!
Okay!
To bundle up!
To drink warm drinks!
Put on fuzzy socks!
And make ourselves cozy as we continue to do our best, okay?
You know, you might be a bit slower than usual.
And that's okay.
You know, it's cold after all, okay?
Be kind to yourself.
I believe in you!
Ganbatte desu!
BAU BAU!
Fuzzy socks number 10.
Yeah, fuzzy socks.
What about the fluffy socks?
If you have fluffy socks I guess that's okay too.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at today's Doggie of the Day!
Yeah!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... That.
Walkie!
Mama!
Oh, is this Walkie's Halloween costume?
I don't know, maybe it's Walkie's first day on the job.
Dog's a job, other than just being a guard dog.
I don't know, but it looks like him!
Walkie was inspired by us!
Really?
Yeah!
Mama!
Do your best, Walkie!
You know, you have a very important job.
To become the best FUWAMOCIST you can be!
I'm a FUWAMOCIST!
I don't know anything about FUWAMOCY.
No.
BAU BAU!
Main Sophisticated!
Right!
Look at that bowtie!
It's blue, Moco-chan.
Pink.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan!
Wow!
Rocky BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
That's not a very clear voice.
I don't know if the old dogs can hear that.
What was that?
It sounds like a car.
What?
No!
That's a walkie, okay?
That's a walkie?
I'm sorry walkie, you sound a little bit like a car.
BAU BAU!
I think Ruffians, we're in good paws here with Walkie, right?
Right!
Look!
Walkie takes things seriously.
Very cute.
And you know what?
Protects their smiles with the curly fluff they chew.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU, this is FUWAMOCO's advertising!
You have to go and see Walkie.
Accurate pricing.
BAU BAU!
Next we have our... Today I went on a walk.
We have De-den!
Oh my gosh, you're able to come and visit a really, really special place to you!
Your favorite childhood park!
You know what?
FUWAMOCO, we're kind of thinking about how it would be so nice to go back and visit some trails and really like exploring as puppies on the Northwest Passage.
Yeah, that would be nice!
Right?
But not quite yet, you know?
But the weather here!
It's beautiful skies.
Blue skies!
The grass and everything!
Thank you for bringing us and sharing such a special place of yours together with us!
FUWAMOCO!
Thank you!
Let's take a look at the Question of the Day today!
Our Question of the Day is
De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
My first meet-and-greet with Shiori and Hatsune was so fun!
Yeah, we're so glad!
Have you been to meet-and-greet event of your favorite singer?
What was your first experience after attending that type of event?
BAU BAU!
We have been!
Our first experience!
Wow, that was an idol that we really, really loved!
And you know, the first thing... Moco-chan, you remember the first thing, right?
Hearing her really super cute voice in the distance!
It's like... Different!
It's different!
It hits you in the heart, in the head drums.
Have a howl of a day!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Hugs are so soft!
We understand a bit, you know, when the Ruffians get nervous or maybe a bit emotional when they meet us for the first time.
We can understand how it was for us too.
Yeah.
We don't want you to be nervous, okay?
No.
There's no reason to be nervous.
I imagine your hands are sweaty.
I don't think my hands are sweaty!
Ruffians!
Me and Rins are scared.
Don't be scared!
We're here to protect your smile, okay?
But it's hard to love fans, you know?
Every time you're like, oh it's kind of scary, I don't know, but doing this, you know?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
BAU BAU!
We hope we can see you soon!
Thank you all for your patience!
We should probably take a look at our next team coming up here!
Our next team is... De-den!
We have...
What's along over on Nerissa's channel?
Yeah, we're watching interview with THE VAMPIRE!
But we are not interviewing a vampire!
No.
But we're doing so all together with Abyss!
So we hope that you'll join us and watch interview with the vampire all together!
I wonder how it will be.
Last year's spooky movies were really spooky.
All we know is it's an interview with a vampire.
And Nerissa wanted to watch it.
Nerissa suggested it.
So I'm thinking it's more a Nerissa movie.
And she also suggested the Barbie movie.
So I'm thinking somewhere in between vampire and Barbie.
That's it!
BAU BAU!
I must take a look at our schedule!
Well, Ruffians, we also forgot to mention something that's very important!
Ruffians!
I wanted to say a big thank you for your submissions today!
We're always looking
For more Pero Sightings, unfortunately, we want to see a Doggie of the Day.
Some just a Doggie of the Day.
Let's jump in.
You walk.
Since you walk, we're waiting for them.
So don't forget to use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Well, we're gonna be racing in Assetto Corsa Cortezion.
Yes!
We sing chorus!
Together with hololive English!
And we have...
No practice.
We're gonna get a wheel.
The wheel's not gonna work.
Not gonna work.
Have we downloaded the game?
No.
But we're gonna practice because we need to practice because the game is very very complicated.
Driving is complicated.
FUWAMOCO!
We're good at driving because we can drive a fast hospital car and ambulance.
What does shifting gears do?
You don't need to shift gears in an ambulance.
Let's go.
Can we just drive the Albion one?
Yes!
But we gotta make sure that we win the race!
And that means we have to destroy the competition.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
And on Friday, well it's Friday so we're spending Friday night on Fridays!
Yeah!
We have five nights on Fridays that are all Friday.
Those nights are Friday.
Yes.
We played the first game almost to completion.
Apparently we're somehow pretty good at it.
I think it's because of the Ruffians.
I think so too.
The Ruffians couldn't make us good again at it.
So please hold our paws okay?
BAU BAU!
And then after that, we're gonna be watching Mikochi-senpai's very first solo concert.
May 8th in the morning.
At 1.45am PT.
We're really looking forward to it.
You can get your streaming tickets on SPWN.
We're gonna be watching there live as it happens.
So we hope that you'll join us for that.
But if you decide not to sleep in, well, you might not get too much sleep after that because we're gonna be playing a very scary game called Vsauce.
Only reason we're playing it is because of Fubuki-senpai.
Fubuki-senpai.
It's Fubuki-senpai's fault officially.
We get to blame Fubuki-senpai.
Fubuki-senpai.
Fububui.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
And then on Sunday, there might be something kinda early on Sunday morning.
We'll see.
And then we're gonna be having a nice, comfy, cozy time chatting and reading some Super Chats all together too.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU!
BAU FIRE!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Not right there!
BAU BAU!
Lettuces!
Pills!
BAU BAU!
Wool!
Tree!
BAU BAU!
Candy corn!
I got banana!
BAU BAU!
Meisei kaigainiki!
Pop Spices!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!